dreck an den händen stört ihn kein
bisschen
der philosoph harald lemke will auch
bauer sein
hauptberuflich denke aber über unser
verhältnis zum essen nach und beackert
selber zusammen mit kollegen bei hamburg
ein stück land lemke will dem essen mehr
bedeutung geben
auch im eigenen leben aber reden wir
nicht sowieso alle ständig über das
essen
die sache ist das ist wesentlich
komplexer also jedes mal wenn ich esse
greife ich in die welt ein
wir sind einfach einen sehr viele
menschen auf diesem planeten und werden
immer mehr
das problem ist dass auf der anderen
seite eben keine endlosen flächen zur
verfügung stehen endlosen ressourcen
wir haben nur diese eine erde und diese
gemengen lage führen dazu dass wir uns
klar werden müssen noch mehr menschen
machen sich das noch klar dass das essen
kein reines privatvergnügen ist sondern
ein politischer akt denken wir also zum
beispiel über unseren wasserverbrauch
nach
wussten sie dass für die herstellung von
einem kilo kartoffeln rund 106 liter
wasser benötigt werden für ein kilogramm
rindfleisch braucht es rund 16.000 liter
wasser weniger wesentlich weniger
fleisch essen würden fallen auch das
fleisch aus massentierhaltung also so
wie das jetzt momentan produziert wird
wenn wir weniger fleisch essen würde
würde es uns allen besser gehen auf
diesem planeten gehören auch sagen eine
eine welt schaffen
die nachhaltig ist für kommende
generation an die gute nachricht wenn
man so will
wir können gut essen ohne so sehr
zusagen über den tod des tieres zu gehen
an dem punkt glaube ich ist eine epische
handlung zu verbinden mit genuss und
fantasie fakt ist der globale
fleischkonsum steigt ständig in den usa
liegt der durchschnittliche
pro-kopf-verbrauch bei circa 115
kilogramm fleisch pro jahr
in der schweiz sind es rund 52 kilogramm
in westafrika liegt der pro kopf
durchschnittsverbrauch bei 7 kilogramm
fleisch den hunger in der welt
840 millionen menschen unterernährt sind
die in armut leben stehen im
unmittelbaren zusammenhang zu unserem
konsumgewohnheiten
es geht um hunger armut
und gerechtigkeit
doch was bitte schön hat unsere
ernährungsweise damit zu tun
dadurch dass wir in den supermarkt gehen
und billig lebensmittel kaufen werden
die menschen die auf dem land leben in
anderen ländern ja die werden schlecht
bezahlt und also kommen sie zu sagen
nicht aus ihrer armut heraus und also
haben sie zu wenig geld um sich zu
ernähren
die zusammenhänge sind komplex sie
hängen aber alle uhr ehrlich miteinander
zusammen und diese kausalitäten zu
verstehen dafür braucht es schon ein
gewisses denken ich nenne es eben die
gastrosophie lemkes gastrosophie
philosophischer blick richtet sich auch
auf die lebensmittelindustrie fairer
handel
ethische produktion jeder einzelne kann
durch sein konsumverhalten mit werken
kultur natur
wichtig waren halt doch eine klare
unterscheidung und was noch wäre der
nächste schritt dass wir alle in zukunft
nicht nur auf fleisch verzichten sondern
sogar auf sämtliche tierischen produkte
also zu veganern werden lebe so viel
veganismus wie du kannst ich plädiere er
für einen kasten hedonismus der besteht
darin dass dass wir uns zeit lassen auch
für diese einsichten also die carnivore
fleisch laste ernährungsweise die wir
jetzt gewohnt sind die ist nicht so
leicht vom verein tag auf den nächsten
abzustellen
wobei ich als ethiker schon sagen würde
das ändert aber nichts an der tatsache
dass wenn man sich die einzelnen
zusammenhänge anguckt wir dennoch
richtig
darin sind zu sagen wir müssen fleisch
komponenten reduzieren
urban gardening also das anlegen und
bewirtschaften von stadtgärten für den
eigenen bedarf für hobby bauer lemke
mehr als ein trend im grunde genommen
wenn man sich die sache genauer anguckt
dann wäre schon gut wenn wir in jeder
stadt jeden stadtteil auf der welt
solche kleinen gärten hätten weil wir
dann etwas machen was eben ansteht damit
wir eine zukunft haben eine
lokalisierung eine eine stärkere
arbeitsintensive beschäftigung also ein
man wegkommt von der industriellen
nahrungsproduktion die nachricht kann
nicht sein werdet wieder bauer ja
sondern werdet teilzeit bauer nutzt ein
stückchen eures wohlstandes eurer zeit
wir haben rieso viel zeit gehabt die wir
für solche sinnvollen dingen nutzen
können wie unsere lebensmittel selbst
produzieren
im grunde geht harald lemke ganz einfach
darum wie sollen wir in zukunft essen
damit sich alle menschen auf diesem
planeten gutachter mundgerecht ernähren
können